the new orleans saints currently seven
and three
but
without drew brees he was placed on
ninja preserve today more on that later
here's sean payton from earlier today
talking about who his quarterback will
be and if he has named a starter
sean is there anything important from a
from a team standpoint just letting them
know who the starter is and announcing
it this friday does that play a role in
it absolutely absolutely and uh
yeah i think everyone's on the same page
how how excited are you just as a play
caller to
to have him be able to have this
opportunity and show it what he can
because it's been a couple years coming
right who who are we talking about
because we haven't
i'm
yeah i'm sorry too because i haven't
announced that either one of those two
were starting
so that was just leaked by someone else
i guess today
i didn't see today or
what you're talking about i was it was
just a headline on espn that taysom was
was going to start yeah i didn't see
that and
and again uh we got a good week of
preparation and uh we're looking forward
to the game just to clarify so no no one
has been in to start
yeah listen someone has been named the
starter but
uh we haven't announced it
in other words get out of here with that
these are not the droids you're looking
for bullcrap sean payton isn't falling
for any of it no jedi mind tricks no
bananas in the tailpipe it's not gonna
work you're not gonna get him to say who
the starter is even though and it was
kind of funny how it happened this
morning first ian rapport of nfl media
tried to kind of in a hedgy sort of way
just two days after he indicated jason
winston jameis winston excuse me would
get the bulk of the snaps he flipped it
over to suggest that taysom hill would
be the starter but didn't quite say it
unequivocally that was chased by adam
schefter saying it unequivocally
unconditionally tasted him as the
starter and jameis winston had no
starter reps in practice this week
shireen so the bulk of the reporting
points to taste some hill
i don't know who's blabbing because it
seems like sean payton's done a pretty
good job
of getting everyone to keep their mouths
shut i will not rule out the possibility
of sean payton
being the one behind some of these leaks
or the possibility of sean payton maybe
creating some deliberate misinformation
for his own strategic purposes
uh he learned well from bill parcells
mike and he knows how to play this game
and it's sort of the same thing they did
last year when drew brees was gonna miss
games and ended up missing five games
and we didn't know initially who was
going to start although we thought it
was teddy bridgewater and yeah i
completely agree with you this very much
could be sean payton pulling some
strings here i'm not going to be
surprised if taysom hill starts i'm not
going to be surprised if jameis wants to
start and i'm not going to be surprised
if jamie jameis winston ends up playing
more snaps
than taysom hill does at quarterback i
do think taysom will play a lot in this
game i think they have to take the
bubble wrap at this point however you
play him you have to play him and you
have to play him a lot but this to me
still has a ton of intrigue for
uh this game how it's exactly gonna play
out and i'm not so certain that how it
plays out this game is gonna duplicate
itself next week sean payton's brilliant
i think he's one of the best if not the
best offensive minds in the nfl right
now and he has a plan for this and i
guarantee you the saints are going to be
competitive in the three games or more
that drew brees misses
i i want to peel back the curtain just a
little bit so people understand how the
sausage gets made
people do talk sometimes people do
deliberately spread misinformation and
what's the downside what happens if sean
payton
gave false information to somebody
what happens if he ends up
using jameis winston extensively what's
he going to say if the reporter gets mad
at him what's he going to say well i
changed my mind sorry you should have
checked back with me i mean there's no
real consequence here if you want to
play that card once in a while if the
goal is to keep the falcons flat-footed
and unprepared and i think that's what
peyton wants to do
i can't go too far into the why i know
this
but given the way everything happened
today and given the way that i was able
to get someone's attention and talk this
through
before the dust really settled on it i
believe it is going to be both i really
do and i'm not reporting it definitely
will be because i think this is an area
where i don't think anybody who says
absolutely what's going to happen is
covered i think a lot of different
things could happen but right now i do
believe we're going to see both guys and
i think who we see more of is going to
be dictated the same way it would be if
you had two running backs and one gets
the hot hand or one fumbles right you're
gonna see more of the other guy so i
think they've got both ready i don't
care that taysom got the all the reps
with the starters and jameis winston got
all the reps with the backups or
whatever reps he would have gotten
unless he's the scout team quarterback
he's in play and no one has reported he
was the scout team quarterback this week
so i i that that's what i'm keeping an
eye on and and it's just kind of fun at
this point to see how it unfolds
and who the starter is and who gets more
of the reps and whether anybody is going
to care to go back to friday and pull
out the scorecard and see who was right
and who was wrong
and here's something else mike sean
payton said well i haven't heard that i
don't read that
okay we know sean payton reads and sees
everything there may be a handful of
guys in the nfl that actually don't do
that sean payton is not one of those
guys he reads and sees absolutely
everything and he knows and he like you
said he may have fed the information but
however it came out he's seen it he
knows what's out there he knows what the
other teams are preparing for who face
the saints in the next three weeks he's
ready for that so i'm with you i think
we see both quarterbacks now i don't
think it's going to be a tom landry
thing from back in the 1970s when he
decided to alternate craig morton and
roger stahlbach by the snap and then
quickly figured out that that wasn't
going to work but i agree with you the
hot hand is going to win the day whoever
has that hot hand is going to get more
reps you know it's funny i had a post
yesterday about a film called braddock
that's going to begin production next
year russell wilson is the executive
producer it's about braddock high school
in the late 50s chuck klausen was the
head coach there when i was at carnegie
mellon and he was the coach of the
football team i did not play on it by
the way i don't want to create the false
impression in that regard would have
been easy to create just that vague
impression but i did not play i did not
attend the games but they had two
separate offenses
and
as long as one scored it stayed on the
field punt or a turnover the the other
entire offense went on what if it's just
something like that with the
quarterbacks hey as long as you do well
you're staying out there we're gonna fl
i doubt that sean payton would do that
but he could do anything he's sean
payton and whatever he does
we're ultimately going to say well he's
a genius so whatever he does must be
right i mean it was funny today to see
some of the tweets kind of like the
finger wagging tweets from reporters
covering the team well we should have
known this because they paid him 16
million guarantee but why the hell
weren't you saying it all week then why
weren't you planting a flag saying it
should be taste some hill because they
paid them all that money not once the
report comes out well you know you know
they're paying taste yeah it makes sense
now they're paying take some hell all
that money come on now we were saying
earlier this week the depth chart points
to taste some hill the money points to
taste some hill but everybody thought it
was going to be jameis winston at that
point now everybody thinks it's going to
be taysom hill i just think i'm going to
sit back and enjoy the show and see what
happens on sunday we're going to talk a
lot more about the saints coming up with
kat terrell of the athletic
she covers the saints there and we will
get more information from her to the
extent she has any more because the
saints are providing absolutely none at
this point
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports